[Musica]
cos'è la poesia e soprattutto come nasce
una poesia è quasi impossibile fissare
una definizione perché la nascita è
sempre un movimento un po come se si
volesse congelare il pensiero di un
innamorato che segue quella mente
l'oggetto del suo amore c'è una formula
però che lo fotografa perfettamente
piero bigongiari dice che la poesia è
una scienza nutrita di stupore è davvero
così
la poesia nasce da una serie di
circostanze impreviste e imprevedibili
estremamente varia ma nella vita normale
quotidiana
un gesto uno sguardo un evento un
oggetto un sogno magari l'illuminazione
di qualcosa che lavorava dentro da tempo
un emozioni che ci attraversa tutti
questi stimoli toccano e azionano le
nostre corde interiori senza che
possiamo davvero controllarle per cui
dopo un iniziale momento di stupore
a volte persino di commozione viene una
voglia irrefrenabile di dire quello che
sta succedendo o di cantarlo di ballarlo
di disegnarlo avviene una specie di
fecondazione ma questo capita a tutti
un poeta quanto se ne accorge si mette
subito all'opera per cercare di
costruire un testo una specie di tappeto
in tessuto di parole vorrebbe fermare il
tempo vorrebbe riuscire a non farsi
scappare via l'energia che lo ha
attraversato e che lui ha percepito in
sé e per provarci deve diventare un vero
e proprio scienziato della parola c'è un
verso di gianfranco lauretano che fa
capire molto bene come lavora un poeta
una volta che si è lasciato stupire e
secondarie dalla realtà senza perdono
non vive nessuno primo gli accenti che
cadono ogni tre sillabe creano un ritmo
regolare molto solido come se questa
fosse una verità evidente a tutti
indiscutibile una specie di sentenza
definitiva
secondo le vocali che sono tutte e
cinque presenti creano una linea di
senso dalla massima apertura la e la che
raccontano la bellezza del perdono alla
possibile chiusura la ue e la alla fine
che raccontano invece la tristezza della
mancanza del perdono seguendo così il
significato del testo
terzo il verso sembra protestare
dolcemente perché la poesia non urla mai
ripetendo come l'unico nascosta tre
volte la negazione
no è impossibile vivere senza perdono 4
la doppia se finale sembra farci
scivolare via dalle mani tutto
lasciandoci vuoti lasciando ciascuno di
noi alla sua solitudine siamo fragili
siamo imperfetti se non impariamo ad
accoglierci l'un l'altro perdonandoci le
nostre imperfezioni è impossibile vivere
insieme e pienamente verrebbe da dire
che questa consapevolezza la forza e la
pressione di questa consapevolezza
a spingere e invitare il poeta ad
affinare i suoi strumenti per esprimere
in un certo modo dovrebbe essere più
chiaro il senso della formula scienza
nutrita di stupore si tratta quindi di
un processo che assomiglia molto a un
concepimento si avverte da segnali sia
fisici sia mentali che qualcosa
misteriosamente è cambiato si è come
incarnato è diventata una parte di noi
una parola un suono che rimbombano
un'immagine che si pianta nella testa
una melodia ritmo che invitano a una
danza a me vengono in mente anche i
movimenti di un bambino che sta nascendo
nel grembo di sua madre quando magari lo
si guarda nelle prime ecografie si
diventa in qualche modo custodi di un
tesoro molto prezioso
ma per uno scienziato della parola la
gravidanza del testo è un corpo a corpo
soprattutto con linguaggio che è il suo
strumento principale per bigongiari
usando un altra metà fra legata al
grembo parla di poeta lavatrice che non
solo genera ma persino rigenera fa
rinascere il linguaggio dato che nella
vita quotidiana tutti lo consumiamo
continuamente giunge a questo punto il
momento del distacco
i testi devono fare la loro strada li si
guarda andare via da lontano e bisogna
lasciarli soli nel mondo
è un po quello che capita quando si
accompagna per la prima volta i figli a
scuola
entriamo nel mio laboratorio poetico si
tratta di una poesia nate nel momento di
grande difficoltà
una malattia grave da qui per fortuna
mio padre guarito
eravamo longiano nel parcheggio del
teatro petrella ci stavamo salutando con
un abbraccio
quando io ho avvertito una scossa
elettrica fortissima come il senso di un
improvviso ribaltamento dei ruoli la
testa di mio padre senza capelli è un
bambino lo tengo vicino tra la scapola
il cuore non sento rumore quando si
appoggia soltanto un fascio sottile di
corpo mi attraversa la schiena come il
ricordo di un tempo che è stato e non è
stato mai più
ero diventato io
a causa di quella malattia il più forte
che si prendeva cura del più debole
nella prima parte del testo c'è una
lettera importantissima tecnicamente si
chiama fonema perché il suono più
piccolo che distingue i significati la o
di lo tengo vicino all'inizio non era
una era una ha la testa di mio padre
senza capelli e un bambino
la tengo vicino tra la scapola e il
cuore
io stavo descrivendo la scena in cui
stringevo la testa di mio padre che così
senza capelli a causa della
chemioterapia mi ricordava quella di un
bambino
poi mi sono accorto che trasferendo il
pronome maschile
io non tenevo più stretta soltanto una
testa ma un bambino vero e proprio
quello che mio padre era diventato o
forse era ritornato grazie a quella
singola lettera
mio padre si è magicamente trasformato
in un bambino intensificando attraverso
la lingua la sensazione che io avevo
provato ma è proprio spostando
l'infinitamente piccolo che sia un atomo
che sia un fonema che si generano le più
grandi reazioni nucleari
la disponibilità a lasciarsi colpire
stupire dalla realtà dal mondo è una
premessa quindi indispensabile se si
vuole scrive un testo poetico ma anche
molto rischiosa può capitare infatti
divenire invasi in maniera anche
fastidiosa persino di venire in qualche
modo violentate nel proprio animo
cosa succede in questi casi una delle
tante possibili risposte è quella di
giuseppe ungaretti in veglia un'intera
nottata buttato vicino a un compagno
massacrato con la sua bocca digrignata
volta il primi luglio con la congestione
delle sue mani
penetrata nel mio silenzio ho scritto
lettere piene d'amore non sono mai stato
tanto attaccato alla vita è una
situazione tremenda in cui la guerra
trasforma in bestie con un corpo
straziato di un amico che entra come una
baionetta nell'animo del giovane poeta
che si mette a scrivere lettere piene
d'amore un lunghissimo silenzio e poi il
colpo finale
non sono mai stato tanto che diventa
immenso così isolato attaccato alla vita
ungaretti ci dice che è legatissimo alla
vita ma come di fianco un dolore così
vasto così straziante così appunto
invadente si tratta probabilmente della
forza del sopravvissuto che l'ha
scampata e quindi in qualche modo è
attaccato alla vita ma nel senso di
avvinghiato tenacemente abbarbicato no
si tratta di molto di più disarmare la
morte il dolore la guerra il male come
togliendo una lettera un uomo poeta
normale infatti avrebbero detto non sono
mai stato tanto attaccato dalla vita
perché nel contesto della guerra il
verbo attaccare questo significa cercare
di fare del male cercare di uccidere
cercare di ferire lui no invece lui
scrive così non sono mai stato tanto
attaccato alla vita ha capovolto
magicamente il mondo ha rovesciato la
violenza il male la sofferenza in amore
grazie alla lingua
continuando a giocare potremmo scoprire
poi che anche in questo testo c'è un
grido nascosto
proprio quello della poesia che umanizza
che dice tre volte no alla guerra e che
suggerisce forse o in alternativa
possibile alla disperazione la poesia
quindi non descrive soltanto un mondo
che esiste già ma in qualche modo ne
crea anche uno completamente nuovo
roberto galaverni dice che piuttosto che
discendere dalla verità la poesia si
muove in direzione della verità
la poesia l'arte in generale è il
miglior antidoto possibile all'ideologia
fra l'altro la parola direzione vuol
dire anche senso io credo che sia una
definizione ottima per qualsiasi scienza
autentica che non imprigiona mai ma
libera apre sempre alla conoscenza ne
parla in qualche modo anche ai mini
dickinson
la bellezza non a causa esiste inseguiva
e sparisce non inseguirla
e lei rimane prova a prendere le onde
del prato quando il vento vi scorre
dentro le sue dita dio provvederà che tu
non ce la faccia mai la presunzione il
desiderio di possesso non aiutano mai
occorre uno sguardo curioso e stupito
bisogna allenarsi a questa apertura a
questa disponibilità prima di trattare
con molta cura e il massimo della
precisione scientifica possibile
il testo che sta nascendo anche perché
una volta venuta alla luce la poesia ci
lascia come prima di nuovo a mani vuote
suggerisce ancora piero bigongiari a
volte però il poeta scopre con molta
sorpresa che è riuscito in qualche modo
a restituire al mondo
si sa che aveva ricevuto è riuscito a
inventare un oggetto strano insieme
leggero e resistente fatto di parole una
specie di navicella spaziale su cui
chiunque se vuole fare un viaggio può
salire anche quando chi l'ha così
sapientemente costruita sarà altrove o
non ci sarà più grazie